so today we're going to talk about
darkened skin spots
what's behind that now the medical term
for that is called melasma
so here we have an overactive melanocyte
which is making too much melanin which
is the pigment so it's going to show up
in a
slightly darkened area on your skin
and there are three main causes one
would be high levels of insulin or
insulin resistance
and this is why you see this in cases
with polycystic ovarian syndrome all the
time
you see these little skin spots all over
what's behind that is high insulin and
if you're not familiar with pcos
the excess insulin is triggering the
high levels of androgen
now the number two cause is high levels
of estrogen
and this is why you would see this in
pregnancy or when someone took
hormone replacement therapy or birth
control pills
and then the third cause would be stress
induced because the cortisol
is too high and there's two main adrenal
conditions you have cushing's syndrome
and you have addison's disease and so in
addison's disease you would see these
darkened little skin spots
throughout the body now because stress
can trigger this
too much sun can also give you these
little spots
as well so it's really a matter of
identifying what's causing this
if it's stress i would take b vitamins
and i would take
more vitamin d3 if the problem is high
estrogen i would actually recommend the
person consume more cruciferous
vegetables and definitely some sea kelp
and then we have the insulin resistance
which is probably the most common cause
and for that we recommend healthy keto
and in a minute
fasting if you're new to my channel i
put the link down below of exactly
how to do it before you go
if you have a question about a product
or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the u.s
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help